[Music]
greek mythology is full of tragedy and
heartbreak and there are few stories as
sad as orpheus and eurydice orpheus was
a renowned poet and musician you could
say he was greek mythology's most famous
bard eventually he met the woman of his
dreams eurydice and together they got
married on their wedding day she came
across a disgruntled sata fearing for
her life she ran unfortunately the grass
was tall and she fell into a nest of
vipers dying to a snakebite orpheus was
overcome with grief every song he played
was full of so much sadness and sorrow
even the gods wept for him travel to the
underworld and find your wife they
advised and so orpheus embarks on a
journey to the underworld to find his
lost love once there his music was able
to convince hades and persephone to
return his wife to him with only one
condition eurydice would have to walk
behind the orpheus until they got to the
surface he could not turn around before
they reached the surface orpheus could
resist no longer and turned to see his
wife's face and she vanished right in
front of his eyes this time lost to him
forever